the sword mage is a master of fire ice
and light they are the top spell damage
dealers in Revelation
every element empowers the sword mages
abilities in its own way when the sword
mage has switched to fire their angel
fire makes the target bird and can
quickly cast for a second time with no
mana cost when ice has been chosen the
sword mage can freeze civilities for a
time with cold shackles the sword made
should be fighting at range so their
robes still get stained they can sweep
several adversaries with searing wake or
hit them hard with an elemental fury of
their choice in close combat the sword
rage relies on their control and defense
skills they may slow their flows with
frigid aura direct a mighty cosmic
ripple at them and slice everyone with
Nimbus rain they might teleport with
cutting step or jump back and apply
lambic step on their assailants if
things go bad Celeste Joe agus will make
the sword mage invincible
sword mages of value team player there
void banishment makes it me sir
invulnerable star sword weakens the
celestial aura
test by the sword mage and their allies
a skilled sword mage controls the floor
battle and in flesh tremendous amounts
of damage